This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the mid-1950s, Steven Chen attended a primary school called Buckingham in Cambridge, Massachusetts, right by the Charles River. At that time, there were no Asians in the whole school, so they were trying to diversify a little bit. Actually, there were exactly two Asians, Stephen and his sister. Every spring, their school had a fair called Buckingham Circus,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。20世纪50年代中期，史蒂芬·陈在马萨诸塞州剑桥市查尔斯河畔的一所名叫白金汉的小学上学。当时，整所学校里没有一个亚裔，所以他们正试图让学生群体变得更多元一点。事实上，当时正好有两个亚裔，史蒂芬和他的姐姐。每年春天，他们的学校都会举办一个叫“白金汉马戏团”的游园会，
with games and activities for the students. Parents would put out a big sale showing off their dishes. One year, Joyce Chen decided to bring in egg rolls. My mom did egg rolls, which were more kind of Americanized egg rolls than the traditional Chinese egg rolls, which were more kind of Americanized egg rolls than the traditional Chinese egg rolls. As in, the egg rolls weren't like the ones Chinese families would typically eat. That's producer Shirley Wong. Her recipe for egg rolls back then used thicker shells and half a pound of hamburger.
有各种面向学生的游乐活动和项目。家长们会摆出大排档，展示并出售他们各自的拿手菜。有一年，钟家彩（Joyce Chen）决定带春卷去。我妈妈做的春卷，比起传统的中国春卷，更偏向美式春卷，比起传统的中国春卷，更偏向美式春卷。也就是说，这种春卷和中国家庭通常吃的不太一样。这是节目制作人雪莉·王。她当时做春卷的秘诀是使用更厚的春卷皮和半磅汉堡肉。
Just thought that maybe it'll be more recognizable for the American public. Just in case the egg rolls weren't well received, Joyce came with a backup, a plate of pumpkin cookies. She dropped off her dishes and went home to clean. When she came back, the egg rolls were missing. And the first thing in her mind was, well, maybe they didn't sell, they didn't know what it was. But as she got to the table, the parents were
只是觉得这样可能更容易被美国公众接受。以防春卷不受欢迎，钟家彩还准备了后备方案——一盘南瓜饼。她放下盘子就回家打扫卫生了。等她回来时，春卷已经不见了。她脑子里的第一个念头是，好吧，也许没卖出去，大家不知道这是什么。但等她走到桌前，家长们
mining the food tables, said, you know, Mrs. Chendos, Ageros that you made, they sold out completely. Can you do and make more? Joyce was thrilled. She made them every year, even after her kids graduated from the school. At the school fair, they would, you know,
纷纷涌向食物展台，对她说：“陈太太，你做的春卷全卖光了。还能再做一些吗？”钟家彩欣喜若狂。她每年都做，甚至在她的孩子们毕业之后也是如此。在学校的游园会上，他们会通过广播系统
announce through the public, the PA system that the Joyce and Agerolls had arrived and people would be rushing over to guess them. Joyce and her family immigrated from Shanghai, pushed out of the country during the Chinese communist revolution. Her father had been a city official and she grew up with a family chef. When she first moved to the US, Joyce had been a housewife. But that experience with the egg rolls changed Joyce's life. After seeing how much people in the US really liked Chinese food, she decided to tap into that market. She wrote a popular Chinese cookbook, she opened one high-end restaurant, and then three more. Joyce eventually became a single mom,
向全校宣布：钟家彩的春卷到货了！然后人们就会蜂拥而上抢购。钟家彩和她的家人从上海移民过来，在中国的共产主义革命期间被迫离开祖国。她的父亲曾是一名市官员，她从小就有私人大厨伺候。刚搬到美国时，钟家彩一直是个家庭主妇。但那次卖春卷的经历改变了钟家彩的人生。在看到美国人确实那么喜欢中国菜后，她决定开拓这个市场。她写了一本畅销的中国菜谱，开了一家高档餐厅，接着又开了三家。钟家彩后来成为了一名单亲妈妈，
and while raising three kids on her own, she also hosted a nationally syndicated show called Joyce Chen Cooks. As I say, chicken feet, O-R-Chinese like it. Chicken feet is really a delicacy in Chinese cooking, so we have to chop them off by a heavy knife. By the early 70s, Joyce Chen was flourishing as an entrepreneur and a celebrity in the cooking world. James Beard recognized her as one of the best when it came to Chinese cuisine. She was even put on a US postage stamp. In 1982, she launched Joyce Chen specialty Foods, a line of Chinese cooking sauces made
在独自抚养三个孩子的同​​时，她还主持了一档全国联播节目，名叫《钟家彩烹饪秀》。正如我所说，鸡爪，老外或者中国人一样喜欢。鸡爪在中国烹饪中确实是一道美味，所以我们必须用重刀把它们砍断。到70年代初，钟家彩已经成为烹饪界风生水起的企业家和名人。詹姆斯·比尔德承认她是中餐领域的佼佼者之一。她甚至还被印在了美国邮票上。1982年，她推出了钟家彩特色食品公司，这是一个生产中国烹饪酱料的产品系列，采用
with high-quality ingredients, products like duck sauce, soy sauce, hoisin, and sesame oil, all bottled and labeled with Joyce's name, and shipped to the grocery stores across the country. The supermarket was a different arena for Joyce. She didn't have much say over how or where their products were displayed. She put her precious namesake into the store's hands. And unfortunately it's something like blind shoes. If you have a shoe, you have to sell it in the shoe store. It's just like that's the way it is. These were gourmet products made with the
高品质原料制作，产品包括鸭酱、酱油、海鲜酱和香油，所有这些都装瓶并贴上钟家彩的名字，运往全国各地的杂货店。对钟家彩来说，超市是一个完全不同的竞技场。她无法对产品的陈列方式和位置发表太多意见。她把以自己名字命名的宝贵品牌交到了商店手里。不幸的是，这就有点像盲人卖鞋。如果你有一双鞋，你就必须在鞋店里卖。事情就是这样，没办法。这些都是用
same ingredients she used in her upscale restaurants. But even so, when she and Steven ventured into supermarkets, they would find her sauces lumped together with all the other Asian items. Joyce Chen's sauces were placed onto a section that's come to be known as the Ethnic Food Isle. If you've ever been to a supermarket in the US, you've probably seen an ethnic food aisle, or maybe it was called international foods, or world foods, the same idea. This is the, it's a small world after all, part of the shopping experience. It's where you'll find ramen next to coconut milk, next to plantain chips, next to harissa. Although ethnic aisles look different in every supermarket, they're often variations
她在高档餐厅里使用的同款优质原料制作的美食产品。即便如此，当她和史蒂芬去超市时，还是会发现她的酱料和所有其他亚洲商品混杂在一起。钟家彩的酱料被放在了一个后来被称为“族裔食品货架”的区域。如果你去过美国的超市，你可能见过族裔食品货架，或者它被称为国际食品货架、世界食品货架，意思都一样。这就是购物体验中“小小世界真美妙”的部分。在这里，你会发现拉面旁边挨着椰奶，旁边是大蕉片，旁边是哈里萨辣酱。尽管族裔货架在每家超市看起来都不一样，但它们往往都是
on the same theme. There is the yogurt section, bread, produce, and ethnic. If you think about it, it doesn't really make sense. It's like food category, food category, and then racial category. This is a very strange way to organize a store. And while so-called ethnic food brands get a chance to feed the American masses, they're still confined to the ethnic aisle, and they may never leave. It wasn't always like this. The ethnic aisle has been evolving quietly over the past 100 years. When nationally owned grocery store chains
同一主题的变体。这里有酸奶区、面包区、生鲜区和族裔区。仔细想想，这其实根本说不通。这就好比是食品类别、食品类别，然后突然来个种族类别。这是一种非常奇怪的商店组织方式。虽然所谓的族裔食品品牌有机会喂饱美国大众，但它们仍然被限制在族裔货架上，而且可能永远无法离开。事情并非一直如此。在过去的100年里，族裔货架一直在悄悄演变。当全国连锁杂货店
sprang up in the 1920s and 30s, they were the first to offer customers self-service grocery shopping with produce, fresh meat, and dry goods all under one roof. But most of these stores operated with one specific clientele in mind. White, middle, and upper class housewives. Supermarkets rapidly spread across the country, but there was a clear divide.
在20世纪20和30年代兴起时，它们是第一批为顾客提供自助购物体验的商店，生鲜、新鲜肉类和干货一应俱全。但大多数这类商店服务于一个特定的客户群体：白人中产和上层阶级家庭主妇。超市在全国迅速蔓延，但存在着明显的鸿沟。
European immigrants in cities like Boston, Chicago, and New York shopped elsewhere. There's almost two kinds of stores. They're the standard grocery store, where mostly stores. They are the standard grocery store where mostly Anglo-American, Germanic, groceries dominate, and you have a store which are Italian, which are Jews, and Greek tastes. Krishnan De Ray teaches nutrition and food studies at New York University. He says these stores run by immigrant entrepreneurs sold the products that their communities like to eat, which include various salad greens, olive oils, and Italian cheeses. To find a hunk of separma jian o da jian, not very common in a standard American grocery store.
波士顿、芝加哥和纽约等城市的欧洲移民则去别处购物。几乎存在着两种不同的商店。一种是标准的杂货店，主要是盎格鲁-美国、日耳曼杂货占主导地位，而你还有一些商店，它们具有意大利、犹太和希腊的风味。克里希努·德雷（Krishnendu Ray）在纽约大学教授营养学和食品研究。他说，这些由移民企业家经营的商店出售的是他们各自社群喜欢吃的食物，其中包括各种沙拉绿叶菜、橄榄油和意大利奶酪。要在标准美国杂货店里找到一大块帕玛森起司，可不是那么常见。
The truth was that most of the Anglo-American population didn't care for Italian food, for example olive oil. For example, olive oil. Nowadays, people host olive oil tastings. But back in the 1920s, Italian olive oil was described as greasy, smelly, and bitter. But over the decades, that perception began to change ever so slightly. Americans started to eat more and more Italian dishes. And then, if the demand becomes high enough, then you will begin to see some of these elements in a grocery store.
事实是，大多数盎格鲁-美国人并不喜欢意大利菜，比如橄榄油。比如，橄榄油。如今，人们会举办橄榄油品鉴会。但在20世纪20年代，意大利橄榄油被形容为油腻、气味难闻且带有苦味。但几十年来，这种看法开始发生了一点点变化。美国人开始吃越来越多的意大利菜。然后，如果需求量变得足够高，你就会开始在杂货店里看到其中的某些元素。
The housewives were getting excited about Italian foods and mainstream supermarkets obliged. Stores began to stock a small amount of imported Italian products, like canned tomatoes, or ingredients for spaghetti and meatballs. But products like olive oil didn't just get added to the section where the other oils live. Krishnendu says that Italian products were considered ethnic, that is, not white, but more foreign and unfamiliar to Americans. Yes, even things like pizza.
家庭主妇们对意大利食品产生了兴趣，主流超市也顺应了这一趋势。商店开始进货少量的进口意大利产品，比如罐装西红柿，或是制作肉丸意面的原料。但像橄榄油这样的产品并没有被简单地添加在其他油类所在的区域。克里希努说，意大利产品被认为是“族裔的”，也就是说，它们不是白人的，对美国人来说更具异国情调且陌生。是的，甚至连披萨之类的东西也是如此。
So around the 1950s, Italian products were given their own little corner of the store, intended for unconventional cuisines at the time. It was more like specialty foods. Here's Stephen Chen again. Everything that was imported, like the olive oils, was put in specialty food section. But because the taste for Italian food was still new to most folks, the specialty section didn't get a lot of attention. It was just kind of there.
所以在20世纪50年代左右，意大利产品在商店里拥有了自己的一小块角落，专为当时非传统的菜肴而设。它更像是特色食品。再次请出史蒂芬·陈。所有进口的东西，比如橄榄油，都被放在特色食品区。但由于大多数人对意大利菜的口味还很陌生，特色食品区并没有受到太多关注。它就只是静静地摆在那里。
And then around the late 1960s, the specialty section really started expanding. That's when foreign foods from outside of Europe became very, very popular. Those small specialty sections got bigger and became more of a fixture in supermarkets. And that's because American tastes were changing fast. For one thing, US soldiers were returning from the Vietnam War, where they had eaten Southeast Asian food. It is almost like if you have the military presence there, and if you are exposed to the local food, you will develop a taste for it.
然后大约在20世纪60年代末，特色食品区真正开始扩张。正是在那时，来自欧洲以外的异国食品变得非常非常受欢迎。那些小的特色食品区越来越大，并成为超市里的常驻板块。这是因为美国人的口味变化极快。一方面，美国士兵从越南战争中归来，他们在那里吃过东南亚食物。这就好比如果你在那里有军事存在，并且你接触了当地的食物，你就会培养出对它的口味。
And when they return home, they expect this kind of food. Veterans like principal scanner from the Simpsons. I spent the next three years in a POW camp, forced to subsist in a thin stew, made of fish, vegetables, prawns, coconut milk, and four kinds of rice. They came close to madness trying to find it here in the States, but they just can't get the spices right. At the same time, international tourism increased significantly, and more Americans were enticed to traveling abroad.
当他们回到家时，他们就会期待这种食物。老兵就像《辛普森一家》里的校长斯金纳。我在战俘营度过了接下来的三年，被迫靠一碗稀薄的炖汤维持生计，里面有鱼、蔬菜、对虾、椰奶和四种大米。为了在美国找到它，他们差点疯掉，但就是做不对那些香料的味道。与此同时，国际旅游业显著增长，越来越多的美国人被吸引去海外旅行。
A new kind of a palette becomes what sociologists call omnivoresness, where instead of disdain and debunking other people's taste, there is a kind of open-mindedness that Americans begin to consume omnivoresily everyone else's food. The biggest game changer was that the US had recently used immigration restrictions for the first time in more than four decades.
一种新口味诞生了，这就是社会学家所称的“杂食性”，美国人不再对别人的口味不屑一顾并加以贬低，而是产生了一种开明的态度，开始像杂食动物一样消费所有其他人的食物。最大的转折点是，美国最近在四十多年来首次放宽了移民限制。
Millions arrived every year, most were from Latin America, Asia, and Africa, with only a small chunk from Europe. Immigrants are coming from these other parts of the world and teaching and training Americans how to eat different kinds of food. Meanwhile, supermarkets were like, okay, here is a new way for us to make money.
数百万移民每年涌入，其中大部分来自拉丁美洲、亚洲和非洲，只有一小部分来自欧洲。来自世界其他地方的移民来到这里，教导和训练美国人如何吃不同种类的食物。与此同时，超市则觉得：好吧，这是我们赚钱的新途径。
In most cases, grocery stores, because they were relatively large grocery stores, they had to have a wider market. They're going for what they think is American or is being Americanized. Through the 1970s, supermarkets were in a frenzy trying to introduce foreign products into their stores. Some American entrepreneurs wanted in.
在大多数情况下，由于杂货店的规模相对较大，它们必须拥有更广阔的市场。它们迎合的是它们认为属于美国或正在被美式化的东西。在整个70年代，超市都在疯狂地试图将外国产品引入他们的商店。一些美国企业家也想分一杯羹。
They launched domestically-produced versions of these international foods, salted and corn syrup just right for the American palate. As these brands were added to the specialty aisles, that section morphed into something new, the ethnic aisle. To promote their products, companies began to use these ethnic aisles in ways that were quite different from other parts of the store. In this section, global flavors were showcased as exotic. One of the biggest producers to do this was an American brand
他们推出了这些国际食品的本土生产版本，加入了适量盐和玉米糖浆，以迎合美国人的口味。随着这些品牌被添加到特色货架上，该区域演变成了一个新事物——族裔货架。为了推广他们的产品，公司开始以与商店其他部分截然不同的方式使用这些族裔货架。在这个区域，全球风味被作为异国情调展示出来。这样做的最大生产商之一是一个美国品牌，
named After A City in southwest China. Try junking for your beautiful body, Try junking for the beautiful taste. in southwest China. Chunking was a Chinese food company, founded by businessman Jino Palucci. Jino was not Chinese, but an Italian American from Minnesota. He started a line of can Chinese ingredients a few decades earlier,
名字取自中国西南部的一个城市。为了美丽的身体品尝重庆，为了美妙的味觉品尝重庆。在中国西南部。重庆是一家中国食品公司，由商人吉诺·帕卢奇（Jino Palucci）创立。吉诺不是中国人，而是来自明尼苏达州的意裔美国人。他在几十年前就推出了一个罐装中餐原料系列，
and by the 60s, he'd perfected a marketing strategy. Chun-king products were based on dishes that non-Chinese people loved to order at Chinese restaurants, except with these, all you need was a can opener. It's not a little variety once a week. Some light oriental dish, like Chao-mei, delicious filling, but not too heavy. can't open it. Chung-king swept the nation. It was a staple of American supermarkets.
到60年代，他已经完善了一套营销策略。重庆品牌的产品是以非华裔人群在餐馆里最喜欢点的中餐菜肴为基础的，只不过有了这些，你只需要一个开罐器。每周来点不同的小花样。来点清淡的东方菜肴，比如炒面，馅料美味但不会太腻。开罐即食。重庆风靡全美。它是美国超市的主打产品。
But Juno was a white man profiting off of Chinese food, and he got there by using growster types and orientalist ideas of the far east. Chung-king created displays where shoppers had to squat under bamboo awnings to get to their can-chow-main. He asked employees to wear rice patty hats while handing out samples. Gina made shopping for Chung-king into an immersive, exotic experience. These are Chunking Egg Rolls. Observe wise men enjoying one.
但吉诺是一个靠中国菜发财的白人，他实现这一点靠的是利用对远东的粗暴刻板印象和东方主义观念。重庆品牌打造了这样的陈列：购物者必须蹲在竹遮阳篷下才能买到他们的罐装炒面。他让员工戴着斗笠分发样品。吉诺把购买重庆产品的过程变成了一种沉浸式的、异国情调的体验。这些是重庆春卷。看智者享用美食。
Very tasty, delicious, a stuffed full of oriental filling. Mmm, scrumptious. Chunking is expert at making. All these things made Chunk, intriguing to the white imagination. To survive on the ethnic aisle meant it wasn't enough to just sell the food, you had to sell the experience of eating something foreign, so that it felt like flying to the faraway lands of East Asia, or visiting Chinatown, or at least like getting a table for two at a Chinese restaurant.
非常可口、美味，里面塞满了东方风味的馅料。嗯，太棒了。重庆品牌是制作……的专家。所有这些都让重庆品牌吸引了白人的无限想象力。要在族裔货架上生存，光是卖食物是远远不够的，你还必须出售吃某种异国食物的体验，让它感觉像是飞到了东亚的遥远国度，或者参观了唐人街，或者至少像是在中餐厅里订到了一张双人桌。
Chunking seized on the idea that shopping on the ethnic aisle could be like eating out a special occasion. But for actual Chinese chefs, like our favorite Chinese mom, Joyce Chen, brands like Chongqing and its competitor Le Choi just drank the whole cuisine down. Yeah, well, there are some people I spoke to and I said, didn't like Chinese food.
重庆敏锐地抓住了这样一个概念：在族裔货架上购物可以像是在外面下馆子过节一样。但对于真正的中国厨师，比如我们最喜欢的中国妈妈钟家彩来说，像重庆及其竞争对手丽钟（La Choy）这样的品牌简直是把整个菜系给极度简化了。是的，嗯，我跟一些人聊过，我说，他们不喜欢中国菜。
I said, is it because you've eaten Chinese food? And I said, yeah, I said, no wonder. Joyce was a world-class chef whose gourmet ingredients were put on ethnic isles right beside canned chalmein. But Steven says his mom didn't actually mind having her product shelf next to Chinese food because it made her brand look way more classy. It wasn't the best tasting food by the Chun standards, but Chun-King helped make Jino a multi-millionaire.
我说，是因为你吃过中国菜吗？他们说，对。我说，难怪。钟家彩是一位世界级大厨，她的美食原料却被摆在罐装炒面旁边的族裔货架上。但史蒂芬说，他的妈妈其实并不介意自己的产品和中餐排在同一货架上，因为这让她的品牌看起来更有档次。按照重庆的标准，这并不是味道最好的食物，但重庆品牌确实让吉诺成了千万富翁。
For lots of American consumers, Chun-King struck the right balance between the foreign and the familiar. Its success proved that this type of marketing is what brings people to the ethnic aisle and gets these products off the shelves. More and more nationalities found their food squeezed side by side onto the ethnic food aisle. There be synchotomile displays next to promotions for EED or the Lunar New Year. With that, it became standard for supermarkets to organize the food of the world in this way. Epcot style.
对许多美国消费者来说，重庆品牌在异国风味和熟悉感之间取得了完美的平衡。它的成功证明了这种营销方式正是将人们吸引到族裔货架前并让这些产品清空库存的法宝。越来越多的国籍将其食品并排挤挤挨挨地塞进族裔食品货架。这里会有辛科德马约节（Cinco de Mayo）的陈列，紧挨着开斋节或农历新年的促销活动。随着时间的推移，超市用这种方式来组织世界各地的食品已成常态。艾克赛特（Epcot）风格。
However, not all food nationalities are treated equally. One cuisine in particular was able to wiggle loose of its reputation. The major foods of the aisle were Chinese, Mexican, and Italian. But this changed in the 1980s because Italian food got reinvented. Cristina new rei links this change to how Italians were perceived in the US as they went from mostly a poor population to an upper-leam mobile one.
然而，并非所有食品国籍都受到平等的对待。其中有一种菜系成功摆脱了其固有印象。货架上的主要食品是中餐、墨西哥菜和意大利菜。但这在20世纪80年代发生了变化，因为意大利菜被重新塑造了。克里希努·德雷将这种变化与意大利人在美国受到的印象转变联系起来，他们从绝大多数是贫困人口转变为向上流动的群体。
As poor Italians stop coming in and Italians climb in terms of political office, in terms of filmmakers, in terms of wine makers, in Napa Valley, the prestige of Italian culture goes up and Italy emerges as a major economic power and a center for design culture. And of course, Krishna Ndu says, the key change for Italian immigrants and their food has to do with race. So Italians today would be considered white.
随着贫穷的意大利人不再涌入，意大利人在政治职位、电影制作人、纳帕谷的酿酒师等方面不断攀升，意大利文化的声望随之上升，意大利作为一个经济大国和设计文化中心崭露头角。当然，克里希努说，意大利移民及其食物发生改变的关键在于种族。所以今天的意大利人会被认为是白人。
And as Italians became part of mainstream white society, so did their food. From the 1980s onwards, Italian food itself becomes fancy. So where Asian, Latin American and other immigrant food stayed ethnic, Italian ingredients weren't treated as foreign anymore. Olive oil, in particular, reflects this major change in the grocery stores. Instead of being on the ethnic aisle, it is now usually found with all the other cooking oils. And people like to swish it around their teeth
随着意大利人融入主流白人社会，他们的食物也随之融入。从20世纪80年代开始，意大利菜本身变得高档起来。因此，当亚洲、拉丁美洲和其他移民的食物依然停留在族裔范畴时，意大利原料不再被视为外国货。尤其是橄榄油，反映了杂货店里这一重大变化。它通常不再位于族裔货架上，而是与其他所有食用油摆放在一起。人们喜欢在牙齿周围细细品味它，
and film themselves literally doing shots of the stuff on YouTube. I'm gonna take you to the four S's, swirling the oil, sniffing the oil, slurping, and then swallowing. The story of olive oil and Italian food in general shows that it is possible to leave the ethnic aisle. All it has to do is to be no longer considered ethnic, which rarely happens. But there actually is another way for food to escape the ethnic aisle.
甚至在YouTube上拍摄自己直接豪饮这玩意的视频。我要带你们体验四个S：晃动油（swirling）、嗅闻油（sniffing）、啜吸（slurping），然后吞咽（swallowing）。橄榄油以及整个意大利菜的故事表明，离开族裔货架是可能的。它所需要做的只是不再被视为族裔食品，这种情况很少发生。但实际上还有另一种让食物逃离族裔货架的方法。
An item can get so popular that grocery stores want to make it as easy to find as possible. We've seen this happen fairly recently. It's, you know, that one red sauce with the white rooster in the bottle and the green cap. Not everyone speaks Sriracha. Sriracha. But Wendy's is fluent. They know in a true face. Hoi Fong Sriracha sauce. Thai sauce, sold by Vietnamese immigrant, went mainstream after blowing up amongst the hipster food truck crowd in 2009. Foodies loved it. It's slightly sweet and spicy, but not too spicy, and it's iconic croin rooster logo graces countless things, from baby onesies to throw pillows. Everyone from AppleWhees to Starbucks has mixed it into their menu.
一件商品可以变得如此受欢迎，以至于杂货店希望尽可能让人容易找到它。我们最近亲眼目睹了这种现象的发生。你知道的，就是瓶子里画着白色公鸡、配着绿盖子的那款红辣椒酱。并不是每个人都会说“是拉差”（Sriracha）。是拉差。但温迪汉堡（Wendy's）对它门儿清。他们深谙此道。汇丰牌是拉差辣椒酱。这款由越南移民售卖的泰式辣椒酱，在2009年火遍嬉皮士餐车圈后成为主流。美食家们对它爱不释手。它微甜带辣，辣度适中，其标志性的公鸡标志装饰在无数物品上，从婴儿连体衣到抱枕。从苹果蜂餐厅（Applebee's）到星巴克的每个人都将它融入了自己的菜单。
Folks wanted it on absolutely everything. I do not want to alarm you, but peanut butter and jelly and sriracha chocolate chip cookies is a recipe that exists. It just grew almost like a cult. You go to restaurants and it's on table tops, like Heinz ketchup is, and I'm telling you, the most Anglo-Avango people use a ton of it. Art Popation consults for specialty and natural food companies. He says Sriracha was so in demand it couldn't just be placed in the ethnic aisle.
人们希望绝对每样东西上都加上它。我无意惊吓各位，但花生酱果酱加是拉差巧克力豆饼干确实是一道存在的食谱。它几乎就像邪教一样不断发展壮大。你去餐馆吃饭，桌上就摆着它，就像亨氏番茄酱一样，而且我跟你讲，最盎格鲁-撒克逊的纯正美国人也狂吃这玩意儿。阿特·波帕蒂安（Art Popation）为特色和天然食品公司担任顾问。他说是拉差的需求量如此之大，以至于不能仅仅把它放在族裔货架上。
It had to be double-stocked in the ethnic aisle and next to other hot sauces. Nothing moves something off the ethnic aisle faster than about of extreme popularity. Art says that's another way for the quote unquote, ethnic products to make the leap. It's really about am I satisfying the majority of my consumers needs and will I sell enough of it
它必须在族裔货架和其他辣酱旁边都进行双重备货。没有什么能比极高的人气更能让一件商品迅速撤离族裔货架了。阿特说，这是所谓“族裔产品”实现跨越的另一种方式。这真正关乎的是：我是否满足了大多数消费者的需求，我是否能卖出足够的量，
to justify me carrying it for a long period of time? He says producers need to generate name recognition around their product, just like Sriracha. Whatever it is, it's up to you to create that interest so that people go running into the stores, and it's compelling enough to say, dear store manager, how come you don't carry, you know, watchery's Thai sauce? The wild success of Sriracha sauce was even more extraordinary considering that Hoy Phong
来证明我长期备货的合理性？他说，生产商需要围绕他们的产品建立知名度，就像是拉差那样。不管是什么产品，激发这种兴趣都取决于你自己，让人们奔向商店，并且这种吸引力足够强大，能让顾客对店长说：“亲爱的店长，你们怎么不卖某某品牌的泰式辣酱呢？”考虑到汇丰公司
has spent nothing on its marketing budget. So basically, it takes a miracle for a product to get so popular. Most products never get that big. Some food producers think it shouldn't be that difficult to leave the ethnic aisle. Arunali is the founder of the brand Volcano Kim Chi in San Francisco. The question of categorization has been on her mind as she looks for ways to promote her products. She recalled her last field trip to a supermarket chain. I saw Korean cup noodles and my impression was why don't they put right next to pasta, there's Asian soba noodle or udon. In the next year, she plans on selling the Korean chili paste gochujang.
在营销预算上花费为零，是拉差酱的巨大成功就更加非凡了。所以基本上，一个产品要变得如此受欢迎简直是个奇迹。大多数产品永远无法达到那样的规模。一些食品生产商认为离开族裔货架不应该那么困难。阿鲁娜·李（Arunali）是旧金山“火山泡菜”（Volcano Kimchi）品牌的创始人。当她寻找推广产品的方法时，分类问题一直萦绕在她心头。她回忆起最后一次去连锁超市实地考察的情景。我看到了韩国杯面，我的第一反应是，为什么不把它直接放在意面旁边呢，那里有亚洲的荞麦面或乌冬面。明年，她计划销售韩国辣椒酱（Gochujang）。
She hopes it gets shelf next to hot sauces in the store instead of on the ethnic aisle. We will have a more better exposure for customers. And having this ethnic aisle, it's limiting people's culinary horizon. More we put things together with other items that people get more exposure and people can try things they would never ever try.
她希望它能摆在店里的辣酱旁边，而不是放在族裔货架上。我们将为客户带来更好的曝光度。而设立这个族裔货架，实际上限制了人们的美食视野。我们越是把东西和其他商品放在一起，人们受到的曝光就越多，大家就能尝试那些他们永远都不会尝试的东西。
Aruna isn't the only one who feels this way. Small companies that make products like Indian pickles, salsa or canned jackfruits would love a chance at being spotted by shoppers who aren't going down the ethnic aisle. And honestly, that might look like abolishing the ethnic food aisle altogether. You have to start integrating categories so that you're not having to put stuff into these segregated, kind of old-school, and really out-of-date ethnic aisles. Errol Schweizer is a former Whole Foods executive and now advises food companies. He has long wanted to do away with the practice of putting all international food on a single
有这种感受的不止阿鲁娜一个人。那些制作印度泡菜、莎莎酱或罐装菠萝蜜等产品的的小公司，非常渴望有机会被那些平时不去族裔货架购物的消费者发现。说实话，这可能意味着彻底废除族裔食品货架。你必须开始整合不同的类别，这样你就不用把东西放进这些隔离的、有点老派且真正过时的族裔货架里了。埃罗·施威泽（Errol Schweizer）是全食超市（Whole Foods）的前高管，现在为食品公司担任顾问。他长期以来一直希望废除将所有国际食品放在单一货架上的做法。
aisle. He hoped to shake things up when he worked at Whole Foods. He tried to integrate some of the ethnic products with non-ethnic products on other shelves. But he says giant stores like Whole Foods can be hard to change. And that's because the way we shop and the way stores organize food is all locked in by this one big complicated system called the planagram. This is like grocery nerd stuff because the planagram is not something that you think about in day-to-day life, but a planagram is essentially a picture with a lot of data.
他在全食超市工作时，曾希望能打破这种局面。他试图将一些族裔产品与非族裔产品整合到其他货架上。但他表示，像全食超市这样的大型连锁店很难改变。这是因为我们购物的方式和商店组织食品的方式都被一个名为“货架图”（planagram）的复杂大系统紧紧锁死了。这就像是杂货店极客才会关心的东西，因为货架图并不是你在日常生活中会思考的事情，但货架图本质上是一张包含大量数据的图片。
U.S. supermarkets have on average over 40,000 items in store. Not only do managers have to keep track of everything, they also have to figure out where to place an item based on where it'll sell the quickest. It's extremely complex and there's a lot of money at stake. That's where planagrams become essential. It's like a chart, you know, maybe a grid with pictures of what a grocery set looks like. So when you look at a bunch of shelves in a grocery store and you back up from the shelf,
美国超市平均在售商品超过40万种。经理们不仅要追踪所有商品，还必须根据商品最快售出的位置来弄清楚将商品摆放在哪里。这极其复杂，并且涉及巨额资金。这就是货架图变得至关重要的原因。它就像一张图表，你知道的，可能是一个网格，上面有杂货陈列样式的图片。所以当你看着杂货店里的一排排货架，然后从货架后退
maybe four or five feet and you look at it, it's like a snapshot. Using these planagrams, supermarkets have every single inch, every single aisle and wall planned down to a T. From the expensive, so-called, each front property near the cash registers to these special displays at the end of aisles, no placement is arbitrary. If a bottle of ranch or a bag of titships goes somewhere, there has to be a strong economic reason behind it. Some shelves get more attention than others. The phrase, I level is by level exists because things that are placed right in the customer's line of sight are most likely to sell.
大约四五英尺去观察它时，它就像一张快照。利用这些货架图，超市把每一英寸、每一个货架和墙壁都规划得精确万分。从收银台附近昂贵的所谓“黄金宝地”，到货架尽头的特价展台，没有一个摆放位置是随意的。如果一瓶牧场沙拉酱或一包玉米片被放在某个地方，其背后一定有强烈的经济原因。有些货架比其他货架更受关注。之所以有“视线即买点”（eye level is buy level）这句话，是因为放在顾客视线正下方的商品最有可能售出。
This gets sticky when it comes to introducing less popular products. Say you wanted to put Korean barbecue sauce next to other barbecue sauces on the condiment aisle Which is one of these attention-gidding areas? A planagram would tell a store manager that putting the less familiar Ethnic Korean sauce on premium supermarket shelf real estate would be a waste of that space Because as art probation says an item like Helmann's Mayo or Heinz Ketchet would just sell better. You're going to sell that 10, 20 times faster than an ethnic item.
在引入不太受欢迎的产品时，这就变得很棘手。比方说，你想把韩国烧烤酱放在调味品过道的其他烧烤酱旁边——这可是最吸引眼球的区域之一。货架图会告诉店长，把不太熟悉的韩国族裔酱汁放在超市黄金货架地产上是在浪费空间，因为正如阿特·波帕蒂安所说，像海尔曼蛋黄酱或亨氏番茄酱这样的商品卖得会更好。你会发现它们的销售速度比族裔商品快10到20倍。
To make the calculation even more fussy, supermarkets work with some of the biggest brands on the shelf to make planagrants. Brands like Coca-Cola, Nestle, or Frito-Lay. These brands decide where their products get placed, and they aren't exactly giving themselves the worst spots. Supermarkets also allow these huge corporations to dictate where smaller brands should go as well. It's very insidious, and this is something
为了让计算更加繁琐，超市会与货架上的一些最大品牌合作来制定货架图。这些品牌包括可口可乐、雀巢或菲多利。这些品牌决定了它们的产品摆放在哪里，而且它们绝对不会给自己安排最糟糕的位置。超市还允许这些大企业决定更小品牌的摆放位置。这非常阴险，而且这是他们
they call category captains. Sorry, I got a little close to the mic, because I got kind of excited to talk about it. Essentially, they've outsourced or farmed out some of that work to their biggest brands in the category, which like, when you think about it, yeah, of course, that's a conflict of interest. It's crazy when you think about that. That's what grocery chains are doing.
称之为“品类队长”（category captains）的东西。抱歉，我离麦克风有点近了，因为我谈到这个有点兴奋。本质上，他们将该品类中的部分工作外包或交给了最大的品牌，当你仔细想想，是的，这当然存在利益冲突。当你仔细想想，这太疯狂了。这就是杂货连锁店正在做的事情。
Talking about like Fox's washing the hen house, right? Errol says this means that a lot of smaller food suppliers aren't getting the chance to compete because they aren't getting spots where shoppers will notice them. When Errol tried to challenge the source plangrams, the big brands that designed them said, well, that's a terrible idea. They would sort of gaslight us saying, well, for every like square inch that you don't give us in this space, we have dated approved that you're losing money and you're not doing your job as good as if you were to give us all that space.
这就好比是引狼入室，对吧？埃罗说，这意味着许多较小的食品供应商没有机会参与竞争，因为他们没有获得能让购物者注意到的位置。当埃罗试图挑战原有的货架图时，设计它们的那些大品牌会说：“这真是个糟糕的主意。”他们会向我们进行某种“煤气灯操纵”（gaslighting），说：“在这个空间里，你每少给我们一平方英寸，我们就有数据证明你在亏钱，而且你没有尽到你的职责，不如把所有空间都给我们。”
Say a supermarket decided to mix everything on the shelves together, ethnic and non-ethnic products. Maybe soap anoodles gets a spot next to SpongeBob Mac and cheese. But that means you're taking it away from ingredients is traditionally served with like Ponzu sauce sauce for example. There is something exciting about using an ingredient beyond its intended purpose, but sometimes when you mix ingredients in unexpected ways, you also risk losing the food's cultural
假设一家超市决定把货架上的所有东西都混在一起，包括族裔产品和非族裔产品。也许荞麦面可以在海绵宝宝通心粉旁边占一个位置。但这意味著你把它从它传统上搭配的原料身边移开了，比如ポン酢（Ponzu，日式柑橘酱油）。将一种原料用于其预定用途之外的事情令人兴奋，但有时当你以意想不到的方式混合原料时，你也面临着失去食物文化背景的风险。
context. It's hard to envision what an ideal situation might look like. In this very interconnected age, ethnic ills are growing longer and longer, as people learn how to use ingredients from many different countries. But do we just keep letting it grow until it encompasses the rest of the world?
很难想象一个理想的情况会是什么样子。在这个高度互联的时代，随着人们学会如何使用来自许多不同国家的原料，族裔货架变得越来越长。但是，难道我们要一直任由它生长，直到它吞噬了世界上的其余部分吗？
Shopping on the ethnic ills can be extremely limiting anyway. Sometimes, I need more than a couple options for fish sauce. It's time for the holidays here at 99 Ranch Market. Find international holiday favorites from around the world at Labo de Galatina. H. Mart, a Korean tradition made in America since 1982. Bigger chains like 99 Ranch or H. Mart which serves Asian groceries or Patel brothers which supplies South Asian products or Badegola Tina which specializes in Hispanic foods these so-called ethnic or international supermarkets bring in 49 billion dollars a year in the U.S
无论如何，在族裔货架上购物会带来极大的局限性。有时，我需要的鱼露选择可不止那么一两种。99大华超市的节日季在这里拉开帷幕。在 Labo de Galatina 寻找来自世界各地的国际节日最爱。H Mart，一个自1982年以来在美国发扬光大的韩国传统。像 99大华或 H Mart 这样的大型连锁店（提供亚洲杂货），或是供应南亚产品的帕特尔兄弟（Patel brothers），又或是专门经营拉美食品的 Badegola Tina，这些所谓的族裔或国际超市在美国每年创造 490 亿美元的收入。
A pretty sizable chunk of the $765 billion grocery industry These stores operate differently They sell to a niche population and cater to their customers sometimes extremely specific needs and they don't have to worry as much about explaining their culture to customers who don't know what's up. Ethnic aisles continue to change but they have not gone away completely not yet and it's still where you can usually find products like Joyce Chen Sausage.
这占了 7650 亿美元杂货业中相当大的一部分。这些商店的运营方式不同。它们面向小众群体，迎合顾客有时极为特殊的需求，并且它们不必太担心向那些不明真相的顾客解释自己的文化。族裔货架仍在不断变化，但它们并没有完全消失，至少现在还没有，而且这里依然通常能找到像钟家彩酱料这样的产品。
After his mom passed away in 1994, Steven took over that part of the company while his sister kept Joyce's cookware business going. A few years back, Steven started making YouTube videos, explaining how to use Joyce Chen Sausage. Hi, I'm Steven Chen, President of Joyce & Foods, and I'm going to show you the Joyce in Hoisin Sauce. Hoisin Sauce. He wanted to teach his audience about Chinese cooking, just like his mom did.
在他妈妈于1994年去世后，史蒂芬接管了公司的这一部分，而他的姐姐则继续经营钟家彩的炊具业务。几年前，史蒂芬开始制作YouTube视频，讲解如何使用钟家彩酱料。嗨，我是史蒂芬·陈，钟家食品公司的总裁，我将向大家展示钟家海鲜酱。海鲜酱。他想像他妈妈那样，向观众传授中菜烹饪技巧。
It's not usually his thing to step into the spotlight. Stephen recalls that when he and his celebrity chef mom would go out to eat, they'd get recognized. The manager would send over a bottle of wine and Stephen would feel a bit embarrassed. But with his videos, he became another face of the company. Why, I think, you know, just by promoting her goods, but, you know, when I promote, I'm promoting the Jewish brand and promoting Jewish promoting Jewish chin in here like a sea in her history. And that's it.
走到聚光灯下通常不是他的风格。史蒂芬回忆起当他和身为名厨的妈妈出去吃饭时，他们会被认出来。经理会送上一瓶酒，而史蒂芬会感到有点尴尬。但通过他的视频，他成了公司的另一张脸。为什么，我认为，你知道的，仅仅是通过推广她的产品，但是，你知道的，当我推广时，我是在推广钟家品牌，推广钟家，在 这里推广钟家陈，就像推广她和她的历史一样。就是这样。
Chicken and cashew nuts. Served with white rice, it's a meal in itself. So you're in a grocery store in another country. Where do you find all your favorite American foods? Well, you go to the American food aisle. Vivian Lay takes us on a grim tour after this. So, I'm here with producer Vivian Lay and producer Vivian Lay from what I understand you want to talk about.
腰果鸡丁。配上白米饭，就是一顿饭。所以你在另一个国家的杂货店里。你在哪里能找到所有你最喜欢的美国食物呢？嗯，你会去美国食品货架。听完这段后，维维安·莱（Vivian Lay）将带我们进行一次残酷的参观。所以，我和制作人维维安·莱在一起，制作人维维安·莱，据我所了解，你想谈谈。
Something that is not the ethnic aisle. Roman Mars, hello, yes. I do have a lot of opinions about the ethnic aisle, but I am here to talk about something that I guess you could say is the funhouse version of it. Okay, let's do it. So this actually came up during one of our edits for the main story, which was produced by Shirley Wong. So Shirley is from the US, but is now living in Melbourne, Australia.
一些不是族裔货架的东西。罗曼·马斯，你好，是的。我对族裔货架确实有很多看法，但我来这里是想谈论一些你大概可以称之为它的“怪诞镜厅版本”的东西。好的，那我们开始吧。这实际上是在我们对主故事进行剪辑时出现的，主故事是由雪莉·王制作的。雪莉来自美国，但现在住在澳大利亚墨尔本。
So we were asking her if there was an international food's aisle in Australia and what was in it. And she said that there was this thing that stood out to her that was actually a different aisle. And it's one that you could probably find in a lot of grocery stores outside of the US. So to demonstrate, I reached out to my friend, Nikolai, who is currently in South Korea. I'm in Busan, a city along the southern coast of South Korea. The extent of their American selection here is basically a three-foot wide section. There are things like A1 steak sauce, maple syrup, classical pasta sauces. They have Heinz ketchup, Heinz
所以我们问她澳大利亚有没有国际食品货架，里面都有些什么。她说有一件让她印象深刻的事，那其实是一个不同的货架。而且你在美国以外的许多杂货店里可能都能找到它。为了演示这一点，我联系了我的朋友尼古拉（Nikolai），他目前在韩国。我在釜山，韩国南部海岸的一个城市。这里美国精选食品的范围基本上只有三英尺宽的一段。这里有 A1 牛排酱、枫糖浆、百味来（Barilla）意面酱。他们有亨氏番茄酱、亨氏
yellow mustard, Heinz hot dog relish. I see little packets of nacho cheese sauce and taco seasoning mix. So, there is this thing that exists in supermarkets outside of the United States called the American Isle, which is exactly what it sounds like. It's part of the supermarket where you could find American foods all kind of grouped together in one section. which is exactly what it sounds like. It's part of the supermarket where you could find American foods all kind of grouped together in one section. Yeah, it's like the strange inverse of this ethnic food aisle story.
黄芥末酱、亨氏热狗调味酱。我看到了小包装的纳酱（nacho cheese sauce）和塔可调味粉混合料。所以，在美国以外的超市里存在着这样一种东西，叫做“美国货架”，听起来是怎样的，它就是怎样的。它是超市的一部分，你可以在这里找到各种美国食品，它们都被归类在一个区域里。听起来是怎样的，它就是怎样的。它是超市的一部分，你可以在这里找到各种美国食品，它们都被归类在一个区域里。是的，这就像是族裔食品货架故事中奇怪的反转。
But what I love about it in particular is it's kind of a funny glimpse into what the rest of the world actually thinks about Americans. What hit Kramit to the aisle. It's kind of like seeing like stereotypes of Americans through the world of like snack foods. But there are actually a lot of funny photos that people posted from the American Isles of supermarkets overseas. Like aside from, you know, A1's takes us and not your cheese, which seem right on the money in terms of like the bulls eye. He just
但我特别喜欢它的地方在于，它有点像是一窥世界其他地方对美国人的真实看法，十分有趣。是什么吸引人来到这个货架。这有点像是通过零食世界看到世界各地对美国人的刻板印象。但实际上，海外超市的美国货架上流传着许多搞笑的照片。除了众所周知的 A1 牛排酱和纳乔奶酪，这些东西在某种程度上似乎正中红心，简直就像是精准命中靶心。他简直
like nailed us on that one. What else do you see in the American aisle? Yeah, so I am going to give you a quick tour of the United States from the perspective of the rest of the world. So I just dropped in a picture below from the USA aisle from a grocery store in Myanmar. Okay. So here it is. That's a lot of jello. Yeah, a lot of jello, a lot of instant jello. We have peppered farm malano cookies, fruity pebbles, of course. And the curveball that I see here is apple cider vinegar, which I never really thought of as an American ingredient, but apparently this grocery store in Myanmar thinks that apple
把我们拿捏得死死的。你在美国货架上还看到了什么？好的，我将带你从世界其他地方的视角快速游览一下美国。所以我刚刚在下面放了一张缅甸一家杂货店美国货架的照片。好的。所以就是这个。有好多果冻。是的，好多果冻，好多速溶果冻。我们有沛珀弗雷姆米兰诺饼干（Pepperidge Farm Milano）、果圈彩虹糖（Fruity Pebbles），当然少不了。我在这里看到的奇招是苹果醋，我从没真正把它当成一种美国原料，但显然这家缅甸杂货店认为苹果
cider vinegar is a very American product. And so below that one, I have a picture from the USA Isle from a store in Belgium. And basically, it's Roop Beer, Coca-Cola, cranberry juice, various flavors of phanta. And then at the very edge of the screen, you can see mayonnaise. So it's a sensibly just soda and mayonnaise in Belgium. Yeah. Well, that's, I mean, I guess that's pretty American too, but you're not going for a lot there. I mean, you're not getting your nacho cheese sauce here, which is a real shame. No, it's a very narrow interpretation of, you know, the USA here. So I have another photo. It's from the North American section of a Spanish
醋是一种非常地道的美国产品。所以在那个的下方，我有一张来自比利时一家商店的美国货架照片。基本上，里面有根杰士（Root Beer）、可口可乐、蔓越莓汁、各种口味的芬达。然后在屏幕的最边缘，你可以看到蛋黄酱。所以，在比利时，它基本上就是苏打水和蛋黄酱。是的。好吧，我的意思是，我想这也挺美国的，但你在这上面找不到太多东西。我的意思是，你在这里找不到你的纳乔奶酪酱，这真是太遗憾了。不，对于这里的美国，这是一个非常狭隘的诠释。所以我还有一张照片。它来自一家西班牙超市的
supermarket. And this is exactly kind of what I think about when I think about encapsulating the American diet into one section. So it's cake frosting, Hershey's syrup, marshmallow fluff, marshmallow. So two different variations of marshmallow, instant cake mix, pop tarts. I see a lot of ranch dressing at the top there too.
北美专区，这正是我在考虑将美国饮食浓缩到一个区域时的那种样子。所以它是蛋糕糖霜、好时糖浆、棉花糖酱、棉花糖。所以是两种不同版本的棉花糖、速溶蛋糕预拌粉、蛋挞（Pop-Tarts）。我看到顶部也有很多牧场沙拉酱。
That's so awesome. I think cake see a lot of ranch dressing at the top there too. I think Kate, good marshmallow, is in ranch dressing. Again, you're really homing in on the quintessential American diet when you have those three things represented. Yes. So, when you see these pictures of the American aisle in foreign grocery stores. Like, what do you think of? Because I see a lot of kind of junky food, comfort food, sweet food. That was similar to what we were seeing
太棒了。我觉得蛋糕顶部也看到了很多牧场酱。我觉得凯特，好棉花糖，就在牧场酱里。话说回来，当你把这三样东西放在一起时，你真的抓住了典型的美国饮食的精髓。是的。所以，当你看到外国杂货店里美国食品过道的照片时。比如，你会想到什么？因为我看到了很多垃圾食品、舒适食品、甜食。这跟我们看到的很相似
in the ethnic food aisle. So what is your interpretation of these sections and other grocery stores? Yeah, so I think the main theory isn't necessarily that other countries are trolling us so much as it is, you know, maybe they might be catering to expats who are away from home and they kind of crave this kind of comfort food thing. So you're going to see, you're going to want to eat like frosting and junk food and stuff
在民族食品过道里。那么你对这些区域和其他杂货店的看法是什么？是的，我认为主要的理论不一定是其他国家在故意捉弄我们，而是，你知道，他们可能是在迎合远离家乡的侨民，他们有点渴望这种舒适食品。所以你会看到，你会想要吃糖霜、垃圾食品之类的东西
when you think about home because it's, there are things that you can't have like this analog in a foreign country. You see the same thing in the ethnic aisle in the United States too. It's not the best stuff. It's not something that you would immediately think of Chinese food when you see like... A can of, yeah, Chow-Man or something like that. Exactly, yeah, exactly.
当你思念家乡的时候，因为有些东西你在国外是无法得到的，就像这种替代品一样。你在美国的民族食品过道里也能看到同样的情况。这不是最好的东西。当你看到……一罐，是的，炒面或类似的东西时，你不会立刻联想到中国菜。没错，是的，完全没错。
So I was just like, it is kind of like impulse by comfort food, I think. Yeah, when I see these, it kind of illustrates the design problem that is present in the ethnic food aisle, is that there's some things just don't have good analogues and you need to place marshmallow fluff somewhere and classifying it as American. Seems that is good as anything. Yeah, that's totally right. And it's, you know, it's kind of funny because, I don't personally shop in, you know, the international section of the supermarket. because I don't personally shop in the international section of the supermarket,
所以我就觉得，这有点像冲动购买的舒适食品，我想。是的，当我看到这些时，它说明了民族食品过道中存在的设计问题，那就是有些东西就是没有好的替代品，你需要把棉花糖膨松剂放在某个地方，而把它归类为美国食品。似乎跟其他任何分类一样合适。是的，完全正确。而且，你知道，这挺搞笑的，因为我个人不会去超市的国际食品区购物，因为我个人不会去超市的国际食品区购物，
and I don't mean that from a high in mighty. No, I know what you mean. We have more choices out here. Yeah, I'm in Southern California. I live by five different Asian supermarkets. So if I need Sriracha, I'm gonna go to the Vietnamese supermarket. But I've noticed something similar
我这么说可不是因为我高高在上。不，我明白你的意思。我们在外面有更多的选择。是的，我在南加州。我住在五家不同的亚洲超市旁边。所以如果我需要是拉差辣酱，我会去越南超市。但我注意到了一些类似的情况
kind of happens here too, at some of the Asian supermarkets that I've been to. So for the most part, a place like H. Mart might organize the store more by product type rather than the country of origin because they have a lot of pan-Asian ingredients there. So you'll have a big row of pickled items from Korea next to China next to Vietnam or noodles from all over the place. They're all grouped together and it looks really cohesive. And it's not necessarily called the American Isle
这里也发生过，在我去过的一些亚洲超市里。所以大部分情况下，像H. Mart这样地方可能会按产品类型而不是原产国来组织超市，因为那里有很多泛亚洲的食材。所以你会看到一排来自韩国的腌制食品，旁边是中国的，再旁边是越南的，或者是来自各地的面条。它们都被归类在一起，看起来非常连贯。而且它不一定被称为美国食品过道
or anything like that, but you will see these little neglected pockets of like random Western products that are popular enough to stock, but seems like the store isn't exactly sure how to integrate them with like everything else. Okay, what are some examples there? Okay, so this is gonna be a little anecdotal. But I was just at the store called Mitzwo
诸如此类的名字，但你会看到这些被忽视的小角落，里面放着一些随意的西方产品，这些产品受欢迎到足以进货，但超市似乎并不太清楚如何将它们与其它所有东西融合在一起。好的，有什么例子吗？好的，这可能有点主观经验。但我刚去过一家叫Mitzwo的超市
this weekend and the story was in my brain already. So they have four aisles of Japanese snacks of chips, cookies, candies, and they're all kind of shelved together by type. And then there's a saddle aisle on the other side of the store that had like goldfish crackers, blueberry jam, instant jello mix, and like dusty, peppered farm cookies. So you have like the stacks. And then over there, it's like the miscellaneous western foods like over there. And you know, at the Vietnamese grocery store that I regularly shop at, there's like these two gigantic aisles for like cookies and candy, like an endless row of Southeast Asian cookies,
这个周末，这个故事已经在我的脑海里了。所以他们有四个过道的日本零食，有薯片、饼干、糖果，它们都是按类型放在同一个货架上的。然后超市的另一边还有一个副过道，里面有金鱼饼干、蓝莓果酱、速溶果冻粉和那种满是灰尘的沛斐发姆饼干。所以你既有这些零食。然后在那边，就像是杂七杂八的西方食品。你知道的，在我经常光顾的越南杂货店里，有两排巨大的饼干和糖果过道，就像一排排不着边际的东南亚饼干，
and on the other side, it's like an endless row of Pan Asian candies. And then in the corner of that aisle, it's like gushers, saltines, and raisin bran, and they're all separated into one section right there. So it's just interesting to see what products the store chooses to include and the way that they've kind of chosen to group them together. Yeah, it all kind of depends on the context of the store. And it totally makes sense to me that, you know, gushers aren't with the rice candy, you know. But, but I mean, you
而在另一边，就像是一排排看不尽的泛亚洲糖果。然后在那个过道的角落里，就像是Gushers水果软糖、苏打饼干和葡萄干麦麸，它们都被分门别类地放在那里的同一个区域。所以看看超市选择包含哪些产品以及它们选择将这些产品组合在一起的方式，真的是一件很有趣的事情。是的，这在很大程度上取决于超市的背景。对我来说完全合理的是，你知道，Gushers软糖没有和米果放在一起，你知道的。但是，但是我的意思是，你
can also make a case for them being together. I mean, there is not an obvious sort of design solution to this because you really are working against what people would expect because you're trying to make it as easy as possible for a customer to come in and know what they want to find, you know? Yeah, yeah. It depends on the customer base, but it is kind of funny how it does go both ways.
也可以为它们放在一起找到理由。我的意思是，这里没有一种显而易见的设计解决方案，因为你实际上是在逆着人们的直觉做事，因为你正试图让顾客进来时尽可能容易地找到他们想要的东西，你知道吗？是的，是的。这取决于客户群体，但有趣的是它确实两种情况都有。
Yeah, it does. It does. It does. It does. Thank you, Vivian. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Shirley Wong and Vivian Leigh, edited by Christopher Johnson, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, music by Swan Rial. Delaney Hall is the executive producer
是的，确实如此。确实如此。确实如此。确实如此。谢谢你，维维安。谢谢。本周的“百分之九十九隐形”由雪莉·王和维维安·李制作，克里斯托弗·约翰逊剪辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯负责混音和技术制作，音乐由斯旺·里亚尔创作。德兰妮·霍尔是执行制作人
Kurt Colestead is the digital director. The resident is Joe Rosenberg, Chris Baroube, Emmett Fitzgerald, Lashemadon, Jason De Leon, Sophia Klotzger, and me Roman Mars. We are part of this stichere and serious exam podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Well, on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pion.org. Candace, teacher, producer, please report to Series XM for assistance to clean up on aisle 90-0. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。常驻人员有乔·罗斯伯格、克里斯·巴鲁贝、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、拉谢玛多、杰森·德莱昂、索菲亚·克洛茨格以及我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是stitchere and serious exam播客家族的一部分，现在总部设在潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上@我 Roman Mars，也可以@节目 99PI org。当然还有Instagram和Reddit。你可以在99pion.org上找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接以及99PI的每一期往期节目。坎迪斯，老师，制作人，请到Series XM报到，协助清理90-0号过道。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。